just about.
>> Welcome to the PDP situation report. I'm
Mike Baker, your eyes and ears on the
world stage. All right, let's get
briefed. First up, what drives the
violence of groups like Kamas,
Hezbollah, and the Iranian regime? Well,
today we're stepping back a bit from the
headlines to look at the ideology behind
the militancy with expert insight from
Raymond Ibrahim. Here on the PDB, we
cover the actions of groups like Hamas,
Hezbollah, and the Iranian regime all
the time. They're not just political
actors. They're driven by a specific
world view rooted, of course, in Islamic
ideology. But what is it about that
ideology that fuels such militancy? What
do these groups actually believe? And
how does that belief system shape their
strategies, their goals, and and their
violence? Well, this is a bit of a
departure from our usual focus on hard
news and day-to-day headlines. But to
understand the conflicts that we cover,
right, we thought it was critical to
understand the ideas driving them. My
next guest has spent years studying
exactly that. Raven Ibrahim is an expert
on Islamic history and ideology and a
former Arabic language specialist at the
Library of Congress. He's best known for
his 2007 book, The Al-Qaeda Reader,
which offers a revealing translation and
analysis of the political and religious
writings of Osama bin Laden and Aean
Alzawahiri. You can also find more of
his work on his YouTube channel at the
Holy War channel. Raymond, thanks very
much for being here with us on the
situation report. We appreciate your
time.
>> Yeah, my pleasure, Mike. Good to be with
you.
>> Thank you. Um, I want to start with a
question that may seem odd, uh, but it's
for the benefit of our of our viewers.
uh if you had a minute, if you got in an
elevator and you had one minute based on
all your your experience uh and all your
work studying Islamic history and
ideology and you had that one minute
ride in an elevator and you had one
person with you in there, what is it
that you'd want to tell them uh about
what you've learned, what you've
studied, what you think?
>> I'd want to tell them, I guess, what I
assume they don't know. And I'm also
assuming they're non-Muslims. And um I
think I'd want them to know that this
particular religion is uh unlike other
religions, it's very political. It's
very in a word tribal. It's us against
them. Uh you as a non-believer are de
facto enemy. and um how they approach
you uh as the enemy. There's different
categories, different levels, but none
of it is anything near or remote to what
western, you know, uh standards of
religious freedom uh come uh
approximate. So basically, you know, it
could be from fighting you to killing
you to enslaving you to now's not the
time and we can be your friend and smile
on your face, but we have to do it
later. Um and that's just uh in a
nutshell that's the doctrine that's the
history that's the uh you know current
situation of Islam despite what they
what everyone says mostly non-Muslims
actually.
>> So um I mean I I I want to expand on
that if I could. I guess my question was
about
>> one minute really short for kind of you
know it has it obviously
>> No, we already Yeah, we already we
already got to the 30th floor in that
elevator ride. So, but but I want to now
we're off the but I want to talk I want
to talk some more about about this. But
I was going to ask you a question that
um but I want to caveat it first and
then you'll understand why when I ask
the question is is that um other
religions not just Islam but you look at
Christianity right you know there have
been a lot of wars fought in the name of
of uh of a Christian god right and a lot
of violence that's been perpetrated in
the name of that religion.
So is it is is it that there is more uh
within Islam that it's it's more prone
to violence because of its doctrine um
and beliefs or
>> I I you see what I'm saying? I'm
struggling to answer to ask the question
here.
>> I understand your Yeah. I mean the point
you're raising has been raised countless
times. That's one of the main responses.
Um, I would argue that Christianity,
okay, there's been wars in the name of
Christianity and you know when you say
that immediately everyone I think is
thinking of Crusades and we need to
actually talk directly about that
because that's the opposite case. It's
actually was a defensive war. But
overall the ultimate point that I'm
trying to say is whe I'm not interested
if a person today goes and shoots up a
mosque and says I'm doing it for Jesus.
What I'm interested in is can they
actually trace it doctrinally and
justify it? And the bottom line is a
Christian can't justify it. Muslims
can't because Islam the prophet uh all
the jurists and the ent it's we're too
it's too long to get into the jurist
prudence of Islam but they're all agreed
to what I had said which is that the kir
the infidel the non-Muslim is the de
facto enemy who must one way or another
be fought subjugated. Okay. It's all
over in the Quran. It's all over in
their again we can get into their
technical names the hadith and the taps
etc. Uh so it's all part of the
religion. So to me that's very much
different than saying a Buddhist decides
to blow himself up and kill people and
he you know he screams Buddha. Yeah he
can do that
>> but that doesn't uh he he can't really
justify it and the same with
Christianity whereas Islam abundantly
justifies it. And um as far as the uh
you know the crusades because I think
what you had just said which is you know
whole you know there's been violence and
war in the name of Jesus and Christ.
Yeah. And that's usually the crusades.
But those are so so much misunderstood
that you know so much of my life work
has become correcting them uh so people
understand exactly what the crusades
were which is they were completely
defensive. These were defensive wars. So
the best you can say is that they
accorded with just war theory which was
and should still be a Christian thing at
least in the premodern medieval era.
Just war was taken for granted. You can
always fight if it's in defense. And the
crusaders were actually defending and
trying to liberate formerly conquered
Christian regions which is the entire
Middle East and the Holy Land of course
and the persecution of Christians. So
again, even the even the crusades, which
is sort of, you know, the creme de la
creme of uh an example of evil
Christians um misusing Christ's name,
was perfectly done in accordance with
just war, and it's nowhere near what
we're talking about, which is the sort
of uh offensive war, jihadist
imperative, which is part and parcel of
Islam.
So the the wording that's that's
developed over the recent times um in
recent times I' you know go back to
let's as a convenient point let's go to
911 right um but you know typically you
you get this these phrases radical
Islamists um radical Islamic group right
whether they're referring to al-Qaeda or
Islamic jihad or whomever ISIS
>> um
>> so is that a is that a misnomer is that
they're it's not so much that they're
radical. They're just they're following
um early doctrine or ideology.
>> Yeah, I I on the one hand I agree there
needs to be a distinction that I can't
we can't just like label every single
Muslim under one thing. On the other
hand, I don't think the current
distinction moderate and radical does it
justice because what it it doesn't make
sense. It implies the correct way to
look at it is the observant Muslim is a
radical and a moderate Muslim what we
call a moderate Muslim is essentially a
laxidasical indifferent Muslim who's
living uh according to 21st century
lifestyle and um whatever parts of Islam
fit he'll allow them and whichever parts
don't fit he won't necessarily allow
them. So I think that is happening in
the world and it wouldn't be correct to
say every single Muslim believes uh in
jihad just like it wouldn't be correct
to say every single Christian believes
in any particular Christian tenant. Um
so yeah the distinction is necessary but
it's also the what's wrong with the
distinction is they're implying that the
guys who do the jihad are somehow not
following correct Islam. And that's
false. They are following correct
doctrinal historic Islam. they're
following it more than a moderate Muslim
is, you know, more of pity. But, uh,
yeah, so that's the distinction.
>> Okay. I think that's really interesting.
And the point that you make, I think, is
is probably universally understood,
which is that, um, regardless of the
religion, uh, you you always have you
have the element that's zealous, right,
that that that follows and believes to
the core uh, the whatever the doctrine
of that religion is. And then yeah, you
got the frankly you got the majority who
pick and choose uh for convenience
purposes, you know, what to do, what to
follow, what to believe. Um, you know, I
I guess I I fall in the latter category.
>> Yeah.
>> And the interesting I think thing about
this is uh if I can if I may just end it
because I think you'll you'll like this
um particular aspect. But when you look
at a fundamental Christian, they're the
opposite of a Muslim. They're supposed
to be kind and turning, you know,
friendly and loving and and that's
because they're following the scriptures
so closely. But when the Muslims follow
their scriptures so closely, and most
Westerners don't know that, but their
scriptures are full of pure intolerance,
pure violence, pure what we would call
today toxic masculinity, patriarchy,
misogyny, all of that is in there. So,
you know, if you lend, if your life is
all about trying to emulate what's
written, uh, the way, let's say, a
Christian is trying to follow the, you
know, the Bible, it's ironic because
you're going to have antithetical
results which reflect the antithetical
nature of the two scriptures.
>> So, let me ask you this. Uh, this again
would sound like a simplistic question.
I realize that. Um but uh if you have an
observant Muslim
um as as you call him um at his core
and this again maybe too simplistic at
his core what does he believe?
>> Well if you want to at least call
yourself a Muslim they're supposed to
believe what's called the five uh
pillars of Islam. And these are like the
most basic fundamental beliefs. One is
of course that there's only one God and
Muhammad is his prophet. meaning that
you know whatever revelation Muhammad
gave that's what we follow which is the
Quran the hadith the s etc and then
there's the prayer you have to pray five
times there's the fasting there's zakat
which is which they translate as alms
and here's another perfect example so
the zakat um and there's pilgrimaging to
Mecca but the zakat just to give you an
idea um it's supposed to be arms that's
how if you speak to someone and they
translate it to you they'll tell you oh
it's look at the good side of Islam they
give charity which is
But most people don't know that actually
in according to Islamic law, this
charity can never go to a non-Muslim.
Again, underscoring that the non-Muslim
is the enemy. Why would I give him
money? Unless it's in the context of
trying to cajol him and win him over to
Islam, then you can sort of uh you know
give money and make contributions. But
again, so I'm just showing you how even
this one aspect that people think is a
good aspect uh itself is reflective of
the intolerance and and divisiveness
that I was mentioning in Islam.
>> Okay. No, that's that's actually
fascinating. U Raymond, a long list of
additional questions, but we have to
take a quick break. So, if you could
stay right where you are. Uh we'll be
right back shortly with Raymond Ibrahim
and more of the PDB situation report.
Don't move.
Welcome back to the PDB situation report
and joining me once again is Raymond
Ibrahim. Uh you can find more of his
work on at the Holy War channel that's
on YouTube. Uh Raymond, thank you very
much for sticking around. I I want to
pick up our conversation and
again this this this probably is a very
open-ended question with a lot of
running room here. Uh, but
the progressive left, right, seems,
maybe I'm going to phrase this wrong,
but seems enamored with Islam, right?
And and I mean, I've had conversations
with a variety of of fairly hard-left
liberals. And, you know, they espouse
this idea that Islam is is, you know,
the religion of peace. and they're very
um they they just seem uh unaware
perhaps of the uh the actual doctrine.
And in particular, I suppose you could
you could look at recent protests over
Israel's actions in Gaza and you I
actually walked through a a protest in
New York uh at one point and there was a
queer for Palestine sign uh that was u
being held up and I thought, well,
that's an unusual thought. Um, what is
it about? Is is it is it just a a clever
disinformation campaign on the part of
of uh some in the M Muslim community?
>> No, actually I would say the Muslim
community is by and large very vocal and
upfront about its uh its beliefs. Of
course, you have you have the the ones
who are engaged in what's known in
Arabic as uh taka, which is basically uh
yeah, dipl diplomatic outreach, if you
want to call it that way. Um that
conceals their true intent. But uh you
know, I'll give you a perfect example.
Somewhere in um it's called Hamrak, I
think, Michigan. And um you know uh it's
now got the the city it has more
Muslims, more than 50% of the population
is Muslim. Okay. And um apparently the
left as you call them were very
supportive of the immigrant Muslim
incoming community and they you know
always catered to them in any way shape
or form and then once the city council
became prime Muslim majority they canled
all the homosexual stuff the the
so-called pride stuff and the left felt
betrayed and they even you know oh we
helped you out how could you do this to
us so there's definitely that dam
dynamic always at work which is you have
foolish leftists doing whatever they can
to empower this particular creed that
actually hates them and very openly says
it hates them. Um and when they come to
power they it shows it hates them. Okay.
So uh I think ultimately this uh you
know what we call the left is uh what
what why they do this or why they would
cater to Islam. It's more a reflection
of uh you know the old maxim you know
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
they just ultimately hate Western
civilization. They hate Christianity. U
they hate morality. So they're going to
try to betress it with anything they
can. And why not why not all of that's
original enemy which is Islam from a
historic point of view. Um so I think
that's really what's going on here. They
just to spite you know everything that's
traditional or Christian or moral we are
going to help the you know the Muslims
that everyone hates because they're
Islamophobes etc. Okay. But, you know,
as you say, gays for Palestine. Are they
not aware that, you know, according to
Islamic law, Muslim uh homosexuals get
stoned. That's why they throw them off
um off the roof because that's an
approximation of stoning because you
fall on the pavement and you die by the
stone. Um that's the logic. It's based
on the Sodom and Gomorrah uh idea. So,
yeah. And and but I mean, I have to also
get this off my chest. I hate the word
the left
>> uh because it really legitimizes uh
something that should not be
legitimized. Um when we say left, we
have in our mind some constructs right,
middle, left, middle is supposedly
objective, right is conservative, left
is liberal. But what we're talking about
now is is pure insanity. Okay, the left
is is for example says there's no
genders or there's a thousand genders.
That sort of thing should not be given
respectability by being called left
because it actually puts it on the
political spectrum. It needs to be
called for what it is. Insanity,
stupidity, you know, or even worse. And
so I think once we do that, because
there's also a war on words, um, and
when we use these words, we actually
legitimize and play their game even
inadvertently. Um, so I think we should
also be cognizant of how we start
labeling things.
>> I take your point. Um, yeah. And I've
never I I I guess I've fallen into that
trap. A lot of people have.
>> I use it, too, all the time. I know. I
mean, what else what else am I going to
say? That's the only word people use.
>> Well, that's that's the problem. Yeah.
It's convenient. It it moves the
conversation along because people
understand the phrasing, I suppose. But,
uh, let me let me ask you about this.
the concept of expansion, the concept of
of uh recruitment, of procilitizing, of
of uh of uh converting
um is that baked into the ideology? I
mean so and and and to what degree is
that um you know an element of if you
look at Europe for example I'm a dual
British citizen US citizen and um you
know in in London for example there's
this there's a fair amount of of uh of
back and forth right now over the degree
to which their open policies over the
years have
>> created an an atmosphere right where
London you know in in the words of a lot
of people London's not London anymore
more or the UK is not the UK or France
or whatever,
>> but you know, and so that's led to sort
of this this Yeah, this led to the
concept of well, but it's it's it's part
and parcel of of the plan. They're
they're they're slowly taking over. I
mean, how do how how do you address
that?
>> Well, okay. So, it's it's actually a
good question. So, jihad, which is again
a doctrinal aspect of Islam, which is
all jihad isn't about forcibly
converting people. It's about gaining
governance all around the world and
enforcing Islamic law. And then within
that you can, for example, if you're a
people of the book, if you're a
Christian or a Jew, you can keep your
religion, but you have to pay tribute
and essentially you become a secondass
citizen. Okay? So you lose a lot of your
rights. Okay? Um and if you're not, if
you're a pagan or you you just get
butchered or convert. That's the classic
understanding of Islam. But within
within that whole view, there's
different forms of jihad. So remember
the word jihad, a lot of apologists will
tell you it doesn't mean holy war. It
means to strive, to struggle. And
they're correct. That is the Arabic
meaning of the word. But in a way that
actually really makes it worse because
it shows you, it underscores again how
multi-entacled the idea of jihad is.
It's not just limited to warfare, even
though that has been its primary
expression historically. So there are
categories of jihad. There's the jihad
of the tongue, jihad of the pen. This is
propaganda, lying or pen. So you're
propagandizing on behalf of Islam to
help empower Islam visav the non-Muslim.
Let's let's say Europe. There's jihad of
the money, which means you contribute.
You pay money to the propaganda
campaign, to the jihad uh groups. You're
a rich Saudi. You don't have to actually
engage in it, but you contribute. And
there's also a little known uh the baby
jihad or the demographic jihad. And this
is the idea of h impregnating uh women,
especially Muslim women, and having as
many babies as possible and literally
outreeding the infidels. And that's
what's happening especially in Europe.
And Muslims have said this multiple
times. They boast about it all the time
going back decades. Uh Marmar Gaddafi of
Libya once talked about how that's going
to happen in Europe and lo and behold it
is happening. You have all these major
capitals. Uh I think London is one of
them where one you know the new the
number one newborn name of newborn baby
boys is Muhammad. Okay. And this is not
just in in the UK. This is all
throughout. So you yeah it's not all
about converting. Of course Muslims will
try to convert you as well and there's
brownie points in it for them. But it's
about gaining power and in fact uh
historically it was better for the
caliphates if people did not convert
because then they can milk them for
tribute and more tax. So there was
actually um they they didn't want people
to convert. It was a way to get off
paying the tribute. So ultimately it's
just about gaining power one way or
another through force through fraud
through babies and the you know
demographic uh overwhelming de
demographic boom. Yeah. All of that is
at work.
How
I'm curious um because you're very
straightforward about talking about all
of this. Um how has the response over
the years been? Um have you noticed a
shift in
in the way people react to uh your your
uh your discussions, your explanations,
your writings?
>> Yeah. I Yeah. Yeah. I think definitely
for sure. especially with my last books
that deal with history because history
is so powerful and there's so much fake
history and history is often the first
premise for the conclusions that we have
about the modern era and u you know so
much of what people think about today
when you go back in especially visav
Islam Europe and and Islam it's the
exact opposite you find out that it was
actually Muslims persecuting and
conquering and killing Christians
including in Europe for centuries um so
I think when people see that how it went
on then things start making sense that
today makes actually sense when you see
jihadists acting the way they are but I
would say despite anything I or anyone
says or what the masses believe which is
all good um the machinery just continues
non-stop and um you know I just made a I
just I made a video and I wrote an
article just to give you an idea about
you know what's happening to the Drews
in Syria right and it's uh basically
under the new Syrian president who's a
jihadist who's an al-Qaeda member
formerly and lo and behold the religious
minority are being attacked and
butchered and and slaughtered and raped
and burned alive. Okay, the Drews over
the last couple of weeks. And to me
though, it's kind of like how is this
news? This is not news. This is you take
jihadists and you empower them and you
throw them amongst minorities. This is
what happens. This is ISIS with the
Yazidis precisely a decade ago. And uh
you know and at the time Donald Trump
used to accuse uh Obama rightfully so of
being the founder of ISIS. That's
actually what Trump multiple times
referred to um uh uh Obama. And I'm
wondering, well, what are you the
founder of Donald Trump? Because you
just said that guy uh Ahmed al-Shar, the
new president, the al-Qaeda guy of
Syria, he said he's a great guy. He
shook hands with him. He's easing 10
sanctions with him, patting him on the
shoulder, and this guy is committing a
genocide. So to me, it's just become
very tiresome. It's the same mechanism.
the US, the West helps jihadists. They
end up commit killing everyone and then
they turn around and bite the hand that
fed them and attack the US. And we're
supposed to offer analysis about this
every other year when it keeps happening
non non-stop. So to me, frankly, it's
getting sickening. Um, so yeah, I think
a lot of the people their eyes are
opening, but the, you know, the leaders
and the powers of the bee are just
they're they're staying the course no
matter what.
Why? And I want to be mindful of time
here, but but to pick up on your point
of why do you think that is? Why, you
know, when you say the leaders of the
Western nations help jihadists,
you know, why
you know there's I always I try to, you
know, simplify things and to me it's
either sheer naivity and stupidity and
whatever or it's something diabolical.
I'm pretty pretty confident it's the
latter at this point because you can't
be that naive and that stupid year in
and year out, decade after decade. This
goes back to Ronald Reagan, you know,
when he was helping the mujaheden
al-Qaeda against Russia in Afghanistan,
they came back and attacked us in 911.
So, it's just uh you know, it is what it
is. I think they have their plan for the
Middle East and uh it involves using
Islamic terrorists to get the dirty job
done is what I think.
That's fascinating. Um, and that gives
me a whole another line of questioning,
but we are out of time. Uh, Raymond, I
hope you'll come back when we when we
call you again. I've enjoyed this
conversation very much.
>> Um,
>> yeah. Yeah.
Come back.
>> Yeah,
>> that would be great. And and again, you
can find more of Raymond Ibrahim's work
at his YouTube channel. That's the holy
war channel. Raymond, thank you very
much for being here on the situation
report.
>> My pleasure. Thanks, Mike.